existieren eigentlich aliens oder sind
wir allein im weltall zehn punkte warum
es aliens gibt welche meint ihr sind
wirklich stichhaltig und welchen ein ja
ein bisschen an den haaren herbeigezogen
mein name ist christoph krachten und das
ist kitsch um science und fiction
es gibt gute gründe warum aliens
wirklich existieren
die zehn populärsten argumente für
aliens gibt es hier in diesem video
manche davon sind stichhaltig andere
kompletter bullshit was meint ihr
schreibt in die kommentare
erstens kornkreisen vor vielen hundert
jahren wurden sie zum ersten mal
entdeckt geometrische figuren in einer
solchen exaktheit dass sie nicht
natürlichen ursprungs sein können und
nur in seltenen fällen haben sich
menschen als deren schöpfer geoutet was
sind sie also sind es botschaften von
aliens die uns warnen wollen
oder senden sie uns damit
friedensbotschaften es ist ein großes
rätsel
zweitens die aliens uhr jeden tag suchen
weltweit tausende computer mit der
software seht rom die frequenzen die
aufgefangen werden nach signalen von
aliens ab jeder kann mitmachen jeder
kann das auf seinem computer
installieren und so steigt die
rechenleistung von jahr zu jahr
wissenschaftler gehen davon aus dass
über kurz oder lang in diesen signalen
einnehmen signal entdeckt wird in 30 bis
40 jahren müsste es der fall sein
zitat ansonsten stimmt etwas nicht
repinski fonds seit menschengedenken
werden sogenannte unidentifizierte
fliegende objekte auf englisch an
identität klein object sogenannte ufos
beobachtet die aliens sollen uns schon
seit ewigen zeiten observieren und es
gibt sogar berichte davon dass sie
menschen entführt und untersucht haben
barry abpfiff die man auf das streng
geheime testgelände sollen 1947 die
überreste eines abgestürzten ufos
gebracht worden sein
es soll in der nähe von roswell in new
mexico abgestürzt sein und sogar
zeitungen haben damals darüber
berichtet seitdem würden dort die
überreste des ufos und die
überlebenden aliens untersucht und
sogar technologien die dort erforscht
worden sein sollen würden heute für
anwendungen geräte und besonders
fluggeräte verwendet werden soll sich
zu einem zentrum für alien kontakte
entwickelt haben und es soll sogar
konferenzen mit extraterrestrischen
lebensformen dort geben fünftens die
entstehung von leben aus der ursuppe
sind die bedingungen auf einen planeten
optimal entsteht quasi gezwungenermaßen
leben auf diesem gestürmt das heißt es
müssen bestimmte grundbausteine des
lebens vorhanden sein wie zum beispiel
wasser und wenn dann noch die richtige
menge zum beispiel an uv strahlung oder
blitzen durch gewitter als wenn energie
vorhanden ist bilden sich immer
komplexere strukturen aus diesen
chemischen grundsubstanzen und
schließlich werden aus diesem komplexen
molekülen die ersten lebensformen die
chemiker stanley miller und herren haben
das in den 50er jahren des letzten
jahrhunderts durch ein experiment
bewiesen dass das funktionieren muss sie
haben diese ursuppe nach gemixt haben
dann energie in form von blitzen rein
gejagt und tatsächlich sind die ersten
organischen verbindungen dort entstanden
wie zum beispiel aminosäuren die
vorstufen zum leben und das spricht
dafür dass die theorie stimmt das
heißt wenn die richtigen bedingungen
auf einem planeten vorhanden sind das
dann über die jahrmillionen
gezwungenermaßen aus den
grundsubstanzen leben entsteht
wasser auf dem mars es ist eine
sensation die raumsonde curiosity hat
wasser auf dem mars entdeckt beim
baggern ist sie ausgestoßen und wenn
man jetzt das klima auf dem mars mit dem
auf der erde vergleich dann stellt man
fest dass in höhlen auf der erde zum
teil sehr ähnliche bedingungen wie auf
dem mars herrschen und in diesen höhen
auf der erde
da gibt es bakterien das heißt es
könnte tatsächlich leben auf dem mars
geben das heißt aliens in form von
bakterien
siebtens alien fossilien aus dem weltall
der astrobiologe dr richard fuller will
fossilien in meteoriten entdeckt haben
die nicht von dieser erde sind das
heißt fossilien von aliens sie
entsprechen zum teil blaualgen die sie
auf der erde gibt aber zum teil sind es
auch lebensformen die hier total
unbekannt sind also für ihn der beweis
dass das alien von zielen sind achten
die nasca linien gegen sie sind die
kornkreise ein klacks auf 500
quadratkilometern in peru finden sich
riesige abbildung von tieren linien und
es gibt sogar ein abbild eines menschen
der der astronaut genannt wird
für diese bilder gibt es viele theorien
und sie sind ein großes rätsel
was hat es mit dieser nasca kultur auf
sich wurde sie von außerirdischen
geschaffen hatten die mitglieder dieser
nasca kultur kontakt zu außerirdischen
sind es botschaften an die
außerirdischen sind die langen linien
landebahnen für außerirdischen es ist
ein ungeklärtes rätsel bis heute 9
exoplaneten jahrhundertelang tappten die
astronomen im dunkeln es war nicht
möglich
außerhalb unseres sonnensystems
planeten zu entdecken
vieles sprach dafür aber es konnte
nicht nachgewiesen werden täglich
sterne wurden millionenfach entdeckt
waren also planeten eine besonderheit
unseres sonnensystems waren wir eine
ausnahme im ganzen universum für das
leben sind planeten unverzichtbar nur
auf ihnen können bedingungen herrschen
die das entstehen von lebensfähigen
komplexen strukturen ermöglicht erst
vor 20 jahren wurden die ersten planeten
entdeckt allerdings war leben auf ihn
nicht möglich inzwischen sind es mehr
als 1000 exoplaneten entdeckt worden
sind und um den stern gliese 20
lichtjahre entfernt im sternbild der
waage kreisen wahrscheinlich zwei
planeten mit erdähnlichen bedingungen
außerirdisches leben wäre dort also
möglich
die größe des universums die drake
gleichung der us astrophysiker frank
drake ist das problem einfach mal
mathematisch angegangen er geht davon
aus dass für die bildung einer
zivilisation lediglich bestimmte
bedingungen erforderlich sind
zum beispiel muss das zentralgestirn des
systems also wie bei unseres
sonnensystems das darf nicht zu hell zu
dunkel zu schwer oder zu leicht sein
der planet auf dem das leben entstehen
kann muss in einem bestimmten abstand um
dieses zentralgestirn herum kreisen
seine rotationsachse wird am besten von
einem mond stabilisiert also wie bei uns
und noch ein paar bedingungen müssen
erfüllt sein
und diese bedingungen die packt man
einfach in diese drake gleichung und die
wahrscheinlichkeit der existenz solcher
planeten kann dann ganz einfach aus
gerechnet werden
allerdings variieren die ergebnisse noch
ein klitzekleines bisschen die
schätzungen gehen von einer
zivilisation bei uns in der galaxie der
milchstraße aus bis zu vier millionen
zivilisation also da gibt es eine
gewisse bandbreite ja was meint ihr wie
viel die zivilisation gibt es wohl in
unserer milchstraße
und was meint ihr was stimmt welche der
zehn punkte sprechen wirklich dafür
dass es aliens gibt schreibt cindy
kommentare wenn er mehr darüber
erfahren wollt ob wir in einer matrix
leben
dann schaut das letzte video und wenn er
mehr über schwarze löcher erfahren
wollt dann empfehle ich euch dieses
video ansonsten ich würde mal sagen bis
dann bleibt dran